salut je m'appelle fabien olicard dans
ce format nous faisons un focus sur un
point précis du cerveau dans les
épisodes précédents vous m'avez demandé
de parler du fonctionnement des
décisions dans le cerveau cette sujet du
jour bienvenue dans matière grise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis
dans cet épisode nous allons vivre
quatre expériences expérience une pas
ici d'abonnés expérience 2
empoisonnement mondiale expérience 3
c'est à vous expérience 4/4 à vous le
tout avec la présence très appréciée de
tibhrine chez votre manière de décider
passe par deux filtres le raisonnement
analytique ou le cerveau traite des
données et les analyses rationnellement
et le raisonnement émotionnel ou
auraient agi sous le coup des émotions
on prend des décisions sans trois savoir
ce qui se passe dans notre tête et sans
savoir si ça se voit tobias d'honneur a
mené une étude en 2014 avec son équipe
de nombreux scientifiques de
l'université d'hambourg
il apparaît que pendant la réflexion la
pupille de l'oeil se dit nat et qu'elle
se dilate encore plus si la décision est
affirmative la prise de décision se fait
donc automatiquement dans le fond de
notre esprit et il suffit que quelqu'un
ou qu'une situation viennent bousculer
notre raisonnement pour qu'on fasse
n'importe quoi et qu'on soit
s'influencer thibault
aujourd'hui on parle donc dès la prise
de décision dans ton cerveau auquel
aucun souci le cerveau qui est un muscle
aussi là c'est pas vraiment un musée
animé ça se travaille comme un muscle
très très bien mais pas fait ça c'est
vachement bien qu'il dit ça parce que
souvent on entend oil cerveau c'est un
musée c'est vrai mais en fait c'est un
organe c'est l'organe le plus grave
encore de lui il peut passer chez
complot exactement
et du coup comme ça le même cerveau tout
le monde en temps normal bien sûr du
cerveau en ligne tout le monde même sur
le principe tout le monde a le même on a
le la même quantité de neurones et
surtout on sait que depuis toujours
notre cerveau il travaille un peu en
mode automatique
ok pour nous rendre la vie plus facile
d'accord du coup il prend des décisions
un peu sans qu'on en ait conscience et
des toits aujourd'hui tu vas avoir
conscience de telles décisions et de la
loire que c'est pas si simple d'usagé
on commence avec un truc de magicien
unis d'arnaqueurs up parfait dufour
envoie ses synonymes
l'idée c'est de faire un bond en totu
c'est peut-être parce que c'est un bon
outil un bon d'accord un bottier un
bonne auto abandonnant 10 mois il ya
trois cartes une rouge et de nous
ok est ton but c'est de retrouver où est
caché la rouge parmi les noirs très très
bien aussi
on mélange et puis toi je te dis que ça
serait d'accord alors ça peut être du
hasard il pas parce que si je te mets ça
comme ça je te dis la rouge au milieu
bien sûr si je mélange un peu lentement
ici exactement et là tu as gagné
rien que ça tant pis ça fait plaisir je
suis content est devenu en tout cas
merci vous sacré de la dopamine dans le
cerveau et c'est le bonheur après je
peux aller un petit peu plus vite
ok tu vois la rouge ici ok je suis
concentré on n'est plus là pour rigoler
peut-être j'ai fait un truc peut-être
j'ai pas fait truc c'est ce qu'il est en
train de se dire qu'on sert à mon avis
ici je pense que c'est très bien ok
super alors ça ça veut dire une seule ça
veut dire que quand tu as décidé de
prendre les bonnes décisions et de
mettre ton attention à ce que vous
voulez ok capable de maîtriser ton
cerveau quai de penser plus qu'à ça oui
c'est ça maintenant on va le faire avec
du hasard complet c'est à dire que au
lieu de manipuler je vais rien faire
d'autre que le hasard il ya toujours le
même concept une rouge et deux noirs et
je vais faire un peu comme dans les jeux
télé au lieu que ce soit des cartons va
imaginer que c'est des rideaux on va
dire que cette carte là ouais c'est la
carte où est caché la voiture donc et
que cette ces deux cartes là c'est les
cartes où sont cachés des chèvres ok
d'accord je mélange et alors là on
arrive à la fin de l'émission c'est la
grande finale c'est le grand bonus
jugeant plus qu'il sait pas où sont les
choses directement et on va voir comment
tu prends des décisions maintenant avec
le hasard le plus complet attends moi il
faut que je sache où est la voiture
ok donc déjà deviné par pur hasard ou et
la voiture m'a dit toi que moi je sais
où aller en q2 présentateur mais dis toi
que une fois que tu en as fait ton
premier choix jean retournerai une donc
et une chèvre donc une mauvaise carte et
aura le droit encore de changer après si
tu es ok donc là pour l'instant tu me
dis je choisis telle carte
celtix ok ça c'est la carte que tu
choisis ouais moi je retourne
celle ci il y avait une chèvre ok ok
d'entretien sur deux maintenant ma
question c'est est ce que tu veux
changer de carte ou pas on dirait
l'émission avec les boîtes
je pense que ma mère je dirais je reste
ma position
tu restes sorte agréation la position
seules celles ciblage et aucune idée
s'est rendu au hasard pur et taper la
merde j'ai grinch evra est à gagner
wasquehal est bas mais je n'ai pas dit
ça c'est ce qu'on n'ait pas une chef du
jt pas une chèvre en retire bon au final
tu as perdu
ouais et au final on se dit merde
c'était 100% le hasard donc on peut pas
prendre de vraies décisions hockey et en
vrai notre cerveau peut prendre une
vraie décision pour nous aider à gagner
ce jeu là même si c'est que du hasard
d'accord et ça c'est ce qu'on va voir
tout de suite le problème de mon petit
hall a été annoncée en 1990 est fait
référence à un jeu télévisé qui
s'appelle mondial en finale il y avait
trois ports devant le candidat dernière
ses portes son cachet deux chèvres et e
super voiture le candidat est au courant
que le présentateur sait où se cache la
voiture
le candidat va devoir choisir une porte
le présentateur ouvrira aussi ensuite
une porte qui n'est pas celle du
candidat et qui n'est pas celle où se
cache la voiture et enfin une fois que
le présentateur ouvert une porte le
candidat a la possibilité de changer
mais la question c'est faut-il changer
de portes et c'est vrai comment le tien
vaut peut le décider
dites moi ce que vous vous choisiriez de
faire est-ce que vous changeriez de
porte ou pas sans donner pour choisir
les joueurs sont influencés par le biais
de nos missions de contrôle qui leur
fait garder leurs portes de départ dans
la grande majorité des cas pour le grand
plaisir de la production vous allez voir
en réalité il faut changer de porte et
ça pour le comprendre il faut penser aux
chèvres plutôt qu'à la voiture parce
qu'au départ il ya deux fois plus de
chèvre que deux voitures
donc si vous choisissez une porte au
hasard vous avez 66 % de chances d'être
sur une chèvre
le présentateur est ensuite obligé
d'ouvrir une porte qui n'est ni la vôtre
celle où l'ia la voiture donc forcément
une chèvre puisqu'au départ vous aviez
de grandes chances de déjà sur une
chèvre le fait que le présentateur vous
ouvre la porte de l'autre chèvre fait
qu'il ya un maximum de chances pour que
la voiture soit la porte tout le
présentateur l'a pas ouverte
c'est le genre de choses que notre
cerveau des tests et dans quelques
instants
je vais m thibault et vous face à un
enjeu de taille énorme sauver 600
personnes de la mort voyons voir comment
vous pourriez gérer cette crise il
attention aujourd'hui cette vidéo est
sponsorisé par toujours moi-même en fait
j'ai une pêche moins mon gars là j'ai
fait plein de trucs aujourd'hui je peux
te dire que là je vais tout dépouillé
j'ai des idées surtout jeu j'ai compris
plein de choses là comment tu fais
comment je fais pour quoi pour être
actif mentalement même matin parce que
moi c'est a vu ce que tu manges tu
regardes tu fais gaffe à ce que tu vois
moi je mange du fioul du curieuse à tous
les petits déjeuners ses 52 pages tu as
de tous est stimule le cerveau des
dossiers un petit peu surtout sur
n'importe quoi c'est très très bon pour
tes neurones ça tu vas en prendre
d'accord ça s'est livrée directement
chez toi c'est dix fois par an s'est
livrée directement chez toi ça c'est les
douze promis qu'ils sont sortis d'un
lien dans la description et en plus de
ça les frais de port sont offerts peu
importe où tu habites dans le monde
tiens prends un peu ça va te faire ni
bien cool et ça c'est dans tous les
paquets de céréales je peux je prends et
gégé les curieuses vaut mieux que tu
passes par le site qui dans la
description quand même en plus tu as des
articles gratuit que tu pourras lire sur
le site directement pour voir si c'est
digeste pour toi ça fait plaisir ça à je
me sens tu vois
[Applaudissements]
pas simple de prendre la bonne décision
vous l'avez vu dans l'épisode précédent
de matière grise nous avons vu que le
cerveau a du mal à être rationnel même
lorsqu'ils veulent l'être en 1981 daniel
kahneman a également démontré un biais
cognitif influençant notre prise de
décision sans vous mentir
et c'est ça qui est incroyable et nous
allons reproduire cette expérience avec
thibaut exceptionnellement juge qui va
nous rejoindre pour former deux groupes
distincts
quant à vous vous serez dans le premier
groupe comme thibault dit le petit mois
tout genre à tout jamais si on s'y
croirait vraiment la petite voix on peut
y le camion on peut mettre une petite
voix en post prod maintenant à libérer
d'auby qu'est ce qu'elle va dire on ne
sait pas non c'est pas mal de gens mais
il sera plein elle a dit abonnez-vous je
crois et je mettais un petit poucet on
va faire un truc a été fait dans les
années 80 par daniel kahneman le fameux
il a le fameux tu le connais pas
retarder encore sur asm est aussi et
nous voient encore d'accord mais non pas
peut-être il habite au dessus petit
kahneman il a fait un truc incroyable
il a dit si je vous dis la vérité hockey
que je ne vous cache rien on paie aucune
option et que je vous demande de faire
un choix je peux quand même vous
manipuler et c'est assez bizarre de se
dire attends s'il n'y a pas de mensonge
est aussi donnent toutes les données si
tu vois s'il utilise pas de mots pas
comment il peut faire il a fait un test
et ce test il marche dans 80% des cas
j'ai envie de l'essayer sur toi et donc
sur vous aussi comme vous ai dit dans
l'intro par contre il va falloir boucher
les oreilles de juju parce que
exceptionnellement jujubes à nous
rejoindre
il imagine que devant toi t'as 600
personnes ok hu
elles viennent de prendre un produit
toxique ok on allume de prendre un
produit toxique et toi tu a pour mission
de les guérir en rade
en utilisant un anti poison tu as le
premier anti poison si tu utilises ça va
sauver 200 personnes sur les 600 hockey
la deuxième option
c'est cet anti poison n'at on sait pas
trop comment il fonctionne
ok on sait qu'il ya 33 % de chances que
ça sauve tout le monde donc mais 66 % de
chances que ça sauf personnes manquaient
donc ça c'était deux options je te les
faits voir ici comme ça c'est plus
simple
l'option une ça va sauver 200 personnes
l'option 2 c'est la roulette russe
un tiers de chances que tout le monde
soit sauvé mais deux tiers de chance que
personne ne soit sauvé ma question et
thibault
quelles options choisies tu étais un peu
jean castex avait lâché en place et des
chiffres du coup vite qu'est ce qu'on
fait couvre-feu
tous nos voeux by vertueux je réfléchis
non moi je serais plutôt option un genre
on sort vraiment on est sûr on y va ok
option une étude softonic ouais ok c'est
validé on le valide
ok on va passer maintenant au deuxième
groupe de deuxième groupe ça va être
jugé je veux lui donner les mêmes infos
que toi mais je vais pas le formuler
pareil donc surtout de tutti rien encore
ça et on va voir ce que elle elle va
choisir
alors jésus imagine que devant toi ya
600 personnes viennent de se faire
empoisonner par un produit toxique
on connaissait pas jusque là à chaque
fois de passer les fêtes dans
l'expérience de bassins virus c'est vrai
qu'on en dise un produit toxique
c'est un produit toxique et tout le
monde s'est dit la seule personne qui
pourra prendre la bonne décision c'est
juju efficace c'est vraiment j'en fais
des statistiques un sondage
les sétois il ya l'option une c'est
celle ci si tu leur donnes ça va tuer
400 personnes il ya 400 personnes qui
vont mourir si tu prends l'option 2 il
ya 33 % de chances que toute personne ne
meurt et il ya 66 % de chances que tout
le monde meurt donc en gros voici tes
deux options options une clk 400
personnes qui meurent option 2 cl tu as
un tiers de chance que personne ne meurt
et deux tiers de chances que tout le
monde quelles options tant que tu
t'écoutes juqu'à usa ni mauvaise et non
il n'y a pas de mauvaise réponse à
d'accord ok avec toi tu prend la 2 oui
donc tu prends celle-ci et tu joues de
la tentative de sauver tout le monde
peut-être ouais ok c'est validé alors je
vous le dis maintenant valider s'avère
que c'est juste un solide et c'est
pourquoi je vous le dis maintenant et
vous allez le savoir aussi tout à
l'heure donc vous n'avez pas choisi la
même et quand ce test a été créée en
1981 dans les deux groupes
le groupe 1 faisait toujours le même
choix que toi thibault le groupe 2
faisait toujours le même du choix que
toi juju et pourtant à chaque fois on a
l'impression que notre décision est la
meilleure voie parce que ça a été
présentée différemment alors que c'est
strictement la même chose en gros
l'option une j'ai dit à thibaut 200
personnes vont être sauvés et 200 sauvé
sur six ans c'est la même chose que 400
morte sur six ans c'est juste le fait
d'utiliser que sauver à chaque fois pour
thibault et de mourir à chaque pôle
emploi qui fait que dans l'option une on
veut sauver les gens et dans l'option 2
on veut pas qu'ils meurent et en disant
la vérité sans rien cacher en donnant
toutes les vraies abstrait et j'ai pu
quand même vous manipulez juste avec ça
donc on a l'impression qu'on prend des
décisions rationnelles
en fait notre cerveau il est très
influençable dans ses prises de décision
donc faut toujours réfléchir
est ce qu'on cherche pas à me faire
choisir un truc plutôt qu'un autre
d'accord un peu beauf ou pas c'est ouf
c'est s'il est vraiment les mots
employés qui peuvent déterminer les
choix qu'on fait
dans le premier groupe environ 80% des
personnes choisissent la première option
dans le deuxième groupe environ 80% des
personnes choisissent la deuxième option
en réalité des deux options n'ont pas de
grande différence est de grande
importance
au contraire elles ont été établies pour
consomme en moyenne 200 personnes mais
il est incroyable de voir que remplaçant
sauver 200 sur six ans par tuer quatre
cent sur six ans on touche directement
nos émotions et on influence directement
la prise de décisions que l'on pense
pourtant rationnel dans l'expérience 4
nous irons encore plus loin tout en
conduisant à 36 il y aurait plus de 250
biais cognitifs différents ils sont
intentionnels mesic de jugement de
raisonnement ou liés à notre
personnalité
ils prennent également contre vos
caractéristiques socioculturelles
maintenant que vous avez ça en tête
passons aux questions on va voir comment
vous en sortez alors le sais tu avoues
thibault c'est que quelques courses a
dit moi je dis moi tous les crimes qu
est ce qu on pense alors dis-moi tu
écoutes je te pose des question que je
vous pose aussi effacement eux ils nous
répondent en commentaire bien sûr et
bien sûr comme ils sont très honnêtes
ils n'attendent pas la réponse pour
répondre moi je ne suis pas comme ça
jamais jamais donc ça joue toujours
pareil sur est ce que ton cerveau va
réussir à faire la bonne analyse
en gros on a deux manières d'analyser
les choses sont émotionnels sont
rationnels hockey et des fois on se fait
un peu mangé par l'un ou par l'autre et
ça nous empêche de prendre la bonne
décision de me voir comment ça marche
chez toi riddim wattoo six chiffres un
homme une allumette et une cigarette
éteinte à la bouche ok il rentre dans
une pièce là lui il ya une pièce un peu
obscur ok il fait très froid il doit
allumer une lampe à pétrole un réchaud à
butane une petite bougie de secours et
met le feu dans la cheminée
la question est qu'est-ce qu'il va
allumer en premier sa cigarette parce
que la cigarette du coup la limmat
arrête
il a beaucoup de choses à abîmer donc ça
va lui prendre du temps donc dit cela
lui met forcément un responsable alors
que celle ci
ça va se consommer doucement du coup il
pourra lui mais plein de trucs après est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
théorie en vrai on est sur un ennui
c'est un non et oui pour moi tu as de
bonnes réponses même si c'est pas
exactement celle qu'on formule mais en
gros il va allumer de l'allumette en
premier un état critique
la veine allumé puisque tu parlais de la
cigarette avec l'allumette nos bons et
en général et je pense que ça va être le
cas aussi dans les commentaires
comme on dit toutes les choses qu'il a
lu et les gens oublient un peu le départ
gay et cherchent à tendre ni value mais
quoi en premier la lampe à pétrole le
feu mais en fait c'est la lumière qui
donne la première étape c'est exact la
mère d'henri a quatre enfants
avril mai et juin sont les trois
premiers
quel est le nom du quatrième henry oui
l'afrique
mais expliquent leur pourquoi parce que
je suis en a quelques uns mais non c'est
juste alors pour je me la pète
mais elle et elle est connue elle est
connue c'est le fait américanité plein
mécanique est connu et du coup il faut
souvent on en oublie le henry le 1er
henri et du coup mais bon si je me la
pète et je dis ouais non mais j'ai
trouvé tout seul en fait réflexion
réflexion voilà se concentrer se
concentrait et donc pourquoi
à la base ce genre de truc ça arrive un
petit peu à nous brainfuck parce que on
écoute mal l'énoncé - départ on se
concentre tout de suite a dit allez
vas-y la fin est souvent la réponse
c'est dans les données et en vrai si on
extrapole ce tout petit truc tout bête
est rigolo c'est beaucoup plus important
ça veut dire qu'il ne faut jamais
oublier les données de départ avant de
foncer tête baissée il faut faire le
point de caisse que je sais qu est ce
que je sais pas mon invité pendant un
contrôle ni
bien non c'est nous sommes en hiver en
plein hiver dans mon jardin thibault
hocquet il tombe deux fois plus de neige
que dans le jardin mon voisin ok
pourquoi
qu'est ce qui se passe à coeur ça je la
connais pas donc on est en hiver
ouais dans mon jardin qui tombe deux
fois plus de lait est je vais pourtant
dans mon jardin il tombe deux fois plus
de neige que dans le jardin du voisin
alors peut-être dans le voisin pour
bâtir notre continent pourquoi il ya
deux fois plus de n'a en fait un petit
détail un enfant trouve direct à des
histoires de vie milliers encore un peu
plus les flux on est adulte mois en trop
il tombe deux fois plus de neige dans
mon jardin chez le voisin parce que j'ai
un jardin deux fois plus grand bar ouais
j'ai trouvé tout seul
doté d'un jardin de vos plus grands
exactement hier était en fait si on est
adulte plus dans nos prises de décision
on cherche des trous d'extérieur
alambiqué alors qu'un enfant assez vite
qu'ils saisiraient mais y en a deux fois
plus bas g12 jardin de basta ce qu
airbus nous inquiète tu parles divers tu
prends acte du truc et ça c'est de faire
le tri dans les informations importantes
banques et revenir en tout cas la source
de la première hypothèse c'est quoi la
plus simple dans une mare il ya quatre
grenouille qui prennent le soleil sur le
rocher
on s'en fout 500 et pour se rafraîchir
trois d'entre elles décident de sauter
dans l'eau combien de grenouilles reste
sur le rocher mais on avait quatre à la
base en attendant l'eau dont il ne reste
qu'une comme ça et là tu vas me dire
bonne réponse
est ce que vous êtes d'accord ils sont
d'accord chez vous dans votre cas
d'accord avec toi
et pourtant vous vous trompez tous il en
reste quatre et ça ça me va me permettre
de dire entre hyper important surtout
mis quand il ou non non non sinon eu
aussi non non non et moi évidemment
j'aurais dit la même chose à la base
c'est la grande différence entre décidé
et faire une action est en fait elles
ont décidé de sauter dans l'eau j'ai
jamais dit qu'elle avait sauté dans
l'autre et c'est un gros problème dans
le cerveau et c'est un gros problème
dans tes décisions dans ta vie parce que
en vrai et pour vous c'est un message
hyper importante faut jamais se dire il
faut que ce soit ça j'aimerais faire ça
j'ai décidé que j'allais faire ça il
faut parler au présent pour se mettre en
action directement d'accord et toi c'est
un truc que tu connais bien de tout ce
qu'ils avouent et non mais j'ai décidé
que j'allais faire du sport ben oui
maintenant fais du sport fait du sport
tout de suite et décide pas que tu en
feras plus tard parce qu'à partir du
moment où tu dis j'ai décidé ton cerveau
crois qu'il a fait oui c'est vrai ils
perdent toute sa motivation pour s'y
mettra et là dessus je rebondis ce que
tu me dis parce que moi il ya une phrase
de ce que j'ai retenu c'est et ne jamais
dire par exemple un projet il vaut mieux
le garder en silence par exemple je veux
faire un marathon
je commence à annoncer à tous mes
proches que je vais faire ce marathon et
du coup mes proches me félicite en amont
que trop tôt walfisz du coup mais bravo
thibault pour ce que tu vas faire et du
coup en fait j'ai de l'endorphine parce
que les gens sont contents dauphinelle
j'ai jamais rien fait payer en trop gêné
par ton cerveau trop tôt pas exactement
et du coup c'est pour ça que enfin que
je retient souvent que qu'importe le
projet qu'on fait de souvent le garder
pour toi tu dessines de le faire tu fais
pour truands et cà la fin quand on est
sûr que c'est quasiment mur là on peut
commencer à en parler mais c'est
l'histoire d'une jeune fille ok une
histoire triste aux funérailles de sa
mère elle aperçoit un jeune homme
qu'elle ne connaît pas ok elle concerne
draghi pendant les funérailles de sa
mère
bah en vrai le trophée antastique c'est
l'homme de ses rêves ah oui clairement
du coup c'est le coup de foudre
et elle tombe folle amoureuse de lui
mais elle connaît pas son prénom elle
connaît pas son nom
et après l'enterrement du poil le père
du hockey quelques jours plus tard cette
même jeune fille tuée sa propre soeur
vous pouvez chercher aussi dans les
commandes qui pourquoi es-tu sa soeur
donc on s'en fout du hand souvent s'en
fout du gars qui a trouvé pourquoi que
ça sort donc sonné sur un autre débat
donc là en fait tu t'es ce moment
brouillés en parlant du beau gosse mais
au final c'est pas la question parce
qu'on parle de sa soeur après je peux
rien
un couac usa sort presque chez moi parce
qu'elle a tué sa mère on garde cette
réponse portois est-ce que quelqu'un
parmi l'équipe ne connais pas cette
question et à une réponse ouais ok est
pas ce qui s'est passé les médias
intéressant des arbres pourquoi parce
que c'est un test qui a été utilisé
entre autres pour détecter les
psychopathes seules personnes qui ont
réussi à trouver la réponse
sans les psychopathes 5 psychopathe
guérir dans cette pièce
ces prédictions et génère 10 ans
guillaume à la bonne réponse
l'oeil par déduction donc elle elle le
tue pour le revoir pour provoquer une
intervention bien joué et est en vrai
dans alors c'est pas que des
psychopathes ont trouvé la réponse
par contre tous les psychopathes ont
toujours trouvé la réponse à cette
question accord la majorité des
personnes qui était un psychopathe vous
ne trouvez pas donc c'est franchement
psychopathe donc tepa psychopathe pièce
s'est longuement fait du jeune j'adorais
poser cette question parce que c'est la
seule question était contente pas voir
ça me va aussi
comme vous l'avez vu il est pas si
simple de prendre une décision rapide et
précise à la fois il faut toujours
prendre le temps de collecter des
données de réfléchir calmement de rester
loin de ses émotions de pouvoir aussi
pesé le pour et le contre
parce qu'au final notre cerveau prend
environ 35000 décisions par jour
emi nous sommes conscients que de 0 26%
d'entre elles
notre conscience de la décision se
réveille uniquement lorsqu'il ya un
enjeu comme on va voir dans quelques
secondes à bord d'un train si dans la
prochaine expérience
[Musique]
nous allons terminer en soumettant
thibault au dilemme du tramway mais en
utilisant un train parce que j'avais pas
de tout le monde
cette expérience est utilisé en éthique
en sciences cognitives et en euros
éthiques elle a été pensée par philippa
foot en 1967 et met notre cerveau à
l'épreuve du stress pour voir comment il
réagit pour la prise de décision oh mais
que vois-je que vois-je
mais c'est elle at il eu des buts il
voilà comment j'évolue très attention
c'est vrai écoutons à un train au cepas
ponceau à haut débit mobile a annoncé
patrick swayze et plus on va on va faire
un test c'est une expérience et c'est
hyper intéressant mettez vous à la place
de thibaut aussi qu'il n'y a pas de
vraie mauvaise réponse je vous parlerai
de tout pourquoi on fait ça après mais
c'est assez intéressant
imaginons qu'on a ce petit train qui
roule comme ça il fonctionne rayon six
mois de préparation on imagine assez
génial fsp sur son aprilia youtube pour
faire une vidéo je fais tourner ce petit
train qui devait faire partir le train
thibault super puisque tu appelles alors
ce train fou auquel il à l'arrêt pendant
deux secondes il sera fou traverser un
bien fou donc ils arrivent ici telle
aiguilleurs est ce que on pourra pas
l'arrêter il n'y a pas de solution de ce
côté là ok donc est ce qu'on lui dit
fais écraser les quatre personnes ou la
personne tout seul tout seul donc dans
la vraie vie tu fais ça tu t'imagines
tapas d'autres situations tu le fais ben
ouais on n'a pas tant de savoir l'âge
des victimes parce que c'est l'âge des
victimes là si son vieux ils sont
bientôt enfin disponible une personne
une personne on tue une personne d'une
personne en voir jean-michel c'est pas
grave
mais les chiens et ça c'est important
c'est vrai que c'est très important
parce que moi les animaux ça c'est
important d'être dans les films je
pleure plus quand il ya un animal qui
m'a réveillé les humains donc bombe du
temps n'est pas remis je suis encore là
la situation reprend ok on est nuls
stevens f passé ok ça va être exactement
la même situation à une petite
différence près c'est que la personne
qui est tout seul c'est antoine à alata
mon petit frère
cet anti frioul petit frère à aa et là
c'est antoine qui est sur le rail tout
seul et de l'autre côté c'est bélanger
quatre autres personnes
la talent heureux leur relationnel qui
prend le dessus sur le rationnel et
maintenant qu'est-ce que tu choisisses
et ça je le connais pas je m'en fous
donc on bourre bousillé quatre vingts
ouais c'est pas grave et d'offrir aux
îles et la change tout voilà forcément
l'effectif prend le pas sur leurs
relations
l'affectif prend le pas sur le rationnel
ouais et sait exactement où je trouvais
ça cool de clôture cool micra 0 bien sûr
il a retrouvé sa vient de terminer en
fait cette vidéo qui parle beaucoup de
comment fonctionnent les décisions dans
le cerveau - est-ce que ça mais vraiment
d'à côté le côté rationnel de ton
premier coup ouais où la majorité des
gens disent beurre on a cassé à cri fier
aux nombres le moins de personnes
possible sur et puis après mais le côté
émotionnel de l'attention si c'est
quelqu'un ta famille alors il ya des
études qui ont été faites sur pourquoi
on sauverait quelqu'un de sa famille et
contrairement à ce qu'on pense ce serait
pas forcément par amour vraiment - une
peine baisse est encore plus profond que
ça c'est en très ancrée dans nos gènes
ça s'appelle la sélection de parentèle
ok en gros qu'on le veuille ou non on
est quand même des animaux à la base et
n'a envie que nos gènes annie perdure
perdure et donc on va sauver ceux qui
ont les mêmes gènes que nous lui
facilement que les autres hôpitaux qui
si on n'est pas extrêmement attachés
juste le fait que ce soit quelqu'un du
parc les mêmes gènes
ça favorise notre choix pour lui
d'accord il ya un autre test qui a été
fait alors qu'elle était fait
virtuellement évidemment on a posé la
même question comme ça des personnes où
on s'est dit on sait que pour arrêter le
train il faudrait quelque chose d'un peu
lourd et encombrant ok pour le mettre
sur la voie et que ça pourrait sauver un
petit peu tout le monde et on a fait la
même situation en disant imaginer qu'il
ya un pont et que sur ce pont y ait une
personne vraiment très très très très
très obèses hockey au point d pourrait
arrêter le train anglais est ce que il
faudrait la laisser tomber
ouais et donc les gens disent bah oui si
ça peut sauver les 4 vies en main et
après on dit est ce que vous la pou
seriez et là c'est encore l'autre chose
au sérieux leur avantageux de non non
moi je tuerai personne et tu vois c'est
tout ça ça montre un truc ça montre que
quoi qu'on veuille la prise de décision
c'est pas si simple c'est toujours un
mélange entre le rationnel et
l'émotionnel c'est là on l'a vu le toi
tu l'assumés c'est marrant à faire mais
c'est vrai que dans la vraie mais on a
pas de cas aussi complexe brothers mais
tout ça pour dire faut pas s'en vouloir
pour les décisions aussi qu'on a pu
prendre dans le passé on oublie le passé
c'est le passé
on peut pas revenir en arrière dessus et
à chaque fois on prend peut-être pas la
meilleure décision
mais on prend la décision de la
meilleure manière possible
tu vois tu trimes où je me dis ça enlève
de la culpabilité aussi sur des fois
est-ce que j'ai pris la meilleure
décision
et ma foi t'a pris celle que tu pouvais
pas à ce moment là il fait vraiment ok
donc merci de m'avoir il avait encore
son seizième ainsi d'invitation c'était
agréable c'est un chèque covidien face
chez covidien
merci à tous les participants à toute
l'équipe à fannie et jérémie la
production à loïc à la réalisation avec
toute son équipe vous avez les nombres
la description et bien sûr à thibaut in
shape n'hésitez pas à découvrir ces
vidéos le lien est également dans la
description vous pouvez cliquer cette
vidéo vous pouvez également la partager
ou vous abonnez à cette chaîne c'est
gratuit et puis les anciens épisodes de
matière grise sont également en lien
dans la description alors pouvons nous
améliorer notre manière de décider
sommes-nous des cerveaux automatisé est
ce qu'on peut être à la fois rationnelle
et émotionnel nous verrons tout cela et
bien plus dans les prochains épisodes de
matière grise
à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]